I'm challenging my rookies to work as a
team to make dinner for the entire
prison so what are they like generally
getting up early in the morning
it all depends if anyone's been bitching
they filmed the brigade can't cook and
constantly bicker but if they pull it
off my business may be in with a chance
[Music]
I've got to launch a product made by
them to the public in a month's time
break it in sweat but there's an eerie
silence morning really 6:30
my Brigade is a man down after Lawrence
walked out
hello mate we've got two minutes right
now I need all the help I can get
and Lawrence is one of the best cooks up
gods I'm afraid our chin someone sure
did you know what a whale come from on
this one we're the same age there's a
quite a nice level of maturity
no no I'm say you're quite dominant
force over Genoa we don't tolerate the
[ __ ] and I'm not here to push buttons
now I'm here to help the last time I
catered for 800 people I had a team of
45 fully trained chefs this time I've
got 12 novices who couldn't make
scrambled eggs at least Lawrence has
agreed to come back let's go guys quick
quick quick
Ronnie let's go come on guys the 800
prisoners always eat in their cells but
we're not improving prison food my aim
is to see if the brigade can carry this
off if they can I might finally have a
team where we're 30 minutes behind
already
five main courses start off with a chili
halau 150 portions 250 portions of a
normal cherry are fat we got two
vegetarian dishes one vegan one
vegetarian 50 portions of vegan and a
hundred portions of a vegetarian baked
after that we're gonna do a chicken and
mushroom pie hundred portions hey guys
guys yeah I need the veg yes I can start
the stop once I got the stock rolling I
can start actually making the chili
we've got 4 under par Shahzad veg prep
is 90 percent of the battle I'm taking a
really big risk and putting
argumentative tests for Jones in charge
take okay yeah look at me nice and calm
and we're working as a team yeah yeah
you're part of that team it's not what
you'd come across like a team member
let's go you got to do 40 tricks
cut back these potatoes oh hey yeah this
is what we came visit this is what we
gotta work with everybody on the ass I
can see that we're not living in luxury
ok as you don't think you'll put on your
pot would you never seen anything like
what Warner Ramsay's doing I'm not
saying that he's gonna change me and I'm
gonna come out I'm gonna be a big change
man and you know I mean I'm going to
heaven all of a sudden and stuff like
that what it's something that you can
hold on to one career criminal I want to
stop ducking and diving is Lawrence by
putting in charge with a main dish of
the day chili con carne
to deploy and you listen
Lawrence is up against it Fresco's he
may not be a team player who is not
afraid of new experiences
I've tried most things the best the best
thing in like the late eighties early
nineties a good time
pastry tell me do you got short crust on
the bottom top based on top yeah have a
look throw in the fridge cockney Anthony
Kelly is running the bakery section
they've got 250 portions of chicken and
mushroom pies too late
[Music]
common sense really it said two eases
when you're not feeding between you know
we've been going to ours the pies are on
track but elsewhere we're in trouble
we're really behind and the vegetable
section factors up because we're we're
struggling with eight hundred servings
of roast potatoes to prepare Tesla and
the veg team are in deep waters and it's
freezing what we're too cold what's the
matter with you
that's too cold get out of here with you
that's you what's the matter with you
Joseph gloves a wet suit to get the
potatoes out